[Musique]
dark side of the moon des pink floyd des
rolling stones le velvet underground ses
vinyles sont gravés dans nos mémoires
ils ont aussi marqué les esprits bien
souvent par l'originalité de leur
pochette comme celle des viandes en 1974
là on ne se rapprochait tu préféré des
fans de neil young généralement on the
beach alors dessus on y voit ni luong de
doha face à la plage très mélancolique
mais il faut surtout dire que millions
qu'à cette époque là il est extrêmement
politisé il l'est toujours d'ailleurs
celle affaire du watergate c'est nixon
il déteste nixon et donc il va récupérer
le journal avec la une qui parle du
début de la sphère du watergate juste
pour faire un petit clin d'oeil à cet
homme-là qu'il n'aimait pas tellement à
partir des années 60 les photographes
les artistes ici le peintre soulage pour
un disque de bartok ou encore les
bédéistes s'empare du vinyle il devient
un mode d'expression incontournable il
ya le côté original et attractif c'est
un nouveau support sur lequel on n'a
jamais travaillé mais on va pas se
mentir c'est aussi parce que ça se vend
la pochette d'album ça se vend c'est un
très bon outil commercial et travailler
pour les grands artistes c'est aussi
s'assurer mais que nos oeuvres elles
vont être aussi vendu en grandes
quantités on fait toujours appel à des
grands graphistes et designers et des bd
est aussi beaucoup plus qu'avant
présente les grands albums de gorillaz
entre autres ont été faits par des gens
qui travaillent dans la bd et ça
continue de plus en plus étant donné que
le vinyle fait son grand retour alors ça
fait un petit moment qui fait cette
version comme retour mais c'est l'objet
musical le plus vendu au monde et du
coup pas forcément les artistes vont
continuer à s'intéresser à cet objet qui
n'a plus rien de mauvais
l'art de la pochette regarde 240 vinyle
l'exposition de l'atelier musée de
l'imprimerie retrace jusqu'au 22 juin
une explosion artistique graphique et
visuel toujours en vogue de nos jours
[Musique]